citizens of the reject Nation Greg here today so
thank you for clicking on this video first off
um secondly we got to see werewolf by night early
we of course shot a reaction to it we can't edit
that or put it up until of course it's out on
Disney plus but I wanted to help contribute to the
word of mouth that's been going around because we
did get to see it before the social media embargo
lifted and social media bargain was the only thing
that's lifted right now so we do got to keep the
thoughts here really short um pretty much like
what would I say in a Twitter thread and here's
what I think I would say in a Twitter thread uh it
is awesome it honors the universal monster horror
Vibe something that I absolutely love I've talked
extensively about it and I really feel like it's
captured truly here it commits fully to its tone
its style its Aesthetics the the lead characters
are great it's a little more violent than I
expected it to be there were times I was like wow
that's actually probably it's really violent it's
not like terrifying in the same sense of how those
classic monster movies were not terrifying uh it
leans more into uh its Soul than just the horror
but there is definitely horror there again I don't
want to say too much but I'll end it off with this
we all thought that it was easily one of the
best things out of Marvel phase four like easily
and it might be one of the best things
out of the MCU it's certainly one of the
most unique refreshing and it's it's just
nice to have something that genuinely feels
inspiring uh to have a direction like this
so yeah guys I I cannot wait for you guys to
hey see our reaction that's the most important
thing uh but B for you guys just to experience
this special watch it with the lights off
now like how we did it but watch it with the
lights off and really get the full immersive
experience um yeah well worth it for sure